Scooter Braun is speaking out as his
feud with Taylor Swift gets even more
complicated and guys he's talking
kindness why you gotta be so on Tuesday
the 38 year old music exec shared a
message on Twitter that seems to allude
to his ongoing beef with a pop star over
the rights to her older music do not let
anything stop you from making art
scooter posted this pic reading kindness
is the only response alongside the
message words to live by
yeah so make with that what you will
of course the post comes amid new
developments in his feud with Taylor
which was reignited last week after she
claimed that scooter Scott Borchetta and
Big Machine Records her former label
were preventing her from performing her
old songs at the 2019 American Music
Awards and stopping the release of a
Netflix documentary about her it's it's
just unbelievable
at the time Taylor shared this lengthy
message on social media in which she
claimed that any recorded event she's
planning to play until November 2020 was
in limbo big machine then fired back
denying the singer's claims saying they
were shocked by her posts that they say
was based on false information adding at
no point did we say Taylor could not
perform on the AMAs or block her Netflix
special a man does something
its strategic a woman does the same
thing it's calculated a man is allowed
to react a woman can only overreact then
they dropped the mic writing Taylor the
narrative you have created does not
exist
oh damn them fighting words I would very
much like to be excluded from this
narrative after a bunch of
back-and-forth statements from both
sides celebs started weighing in and
taking sides
Taylor's bestie Selena Gomez shared this
message on her instace story writing my
heart is so heavy right now it makes me
sick and extremely angry you've robbed
and crushed one of our best songwriters
of our time an opportunity to celebrate
all of her music with fans and
world meanwhile Justin Bieber came out
in support of scooter who we should
mention is his longtime manager on
Monday big machine Label Group released
another statement insisting that they
and Dick Clark Productions have come to
terms on a licensing agreement that
approves their artists performances to
stream post show and for rebroadcast on
mutually approved platforms this
includes the upcoming American Music
Awards performance but shortly after
that statement was released Dick Clark
Productions told et in a statement quote
at no time - Dick Clark Productions
agree to create authorize or distribute
a statement in partnership with Big
Machine Label Group regarding Taylor
Swift's performance at the 2019 American
Music Awards any final agreement on this
matter needs to be made directly with
Taylor Swift's management team um who
else is so dizzy from all this drama
just me okay
well something tells me there's so much
more to come so make sure to keep it
locked right here on ut for all the
updates on Taylor and scooters epic feud
I'm Hallie Stevens see you next time
[Music]